ich habe mal wieder ein paket von amazon
bekommen und wir wollten jetzt einfach
mal das paket zurückverfolgen dh den
ganzen weg vom klick auf bestellen
online bis zur lieferung durch den boden
und los geht's ich habe ein kilo
espressobohnen mit der ms net stellt in
frankenthal beginnt die reise der wohnen
hier ist eines von zwölf logistikzentren
in deutschland allein das gebäude hat
eine fläche von zwölf fußballfeldern
1600 menschen arbeiten hier elf
millionen artikel lagern in unzähligen
regalen eine halbe million davon
verlassen an spitzentagen die halle
täglich liefern lastwagen neue war die
muss im system aufgenommen werden auch
meine bohnen sind irgendwann mal diesen
weg gegangen
ein sogenannter receiver scannt dazu den
strichcode der artikel und schwupps sind
die produkte oft wissen gelistet der
receiver befüllt die kisten nach
belieben es herrscht keine ordnung mehr
achtet nur darauf dass die ware nicht
aus der kiste ragt die förderbänder
schlängeln sich über 18 kilometer durch
die hallen
kommen die kisten auf der zweiten ebene
an wird sie kommen zur porta auf twitter
rollbahnen gestapelt die verteilung an
die 140 stationen wo die artikel gleich
eingelagert werden ist unabhängig vom
inhalt der kisten von diesen gelben
regalen gibt es 35.000 stück die tonnen
orangefarbenen robotern bewegt werden
wir befinden uns hier im bereich asp das
ist die robotik storage platform
diese ist gekennzeichnet letztlich durch
umschlossene bereiche in denen sich
automatisierte transportfahrzeuge
bewegen und die gelben regale aufnehmen
und zur parade ist nämlich den einlagern
und den kommissionieren bewegen wir in
seon ag in der artikel ja wir haben
beispielsweise die geordnete tüte mit
kaffeebohnen oder wo man fußball oder
ein hammer dass es sehr schwierig diesen
artikel zugreifen und das eben
maschinell abzubilden und auch schnell
abzubilden da ist momentan der mensch
noch weit schneller weit fähiger gleich
ist die wahre verstaut der store muss
nur noch die bares kennen und sie mit
dem fach verheiraten
es gibt nur eine regel nicht mehr als
sechs produkte in einfach ab jetzt
warten die artikel darauf bestellt zu
werden wenn es soweit ist fährt das
regal zum pk der schaut einfach auf den
bildschirm dort wird genau angezeigt in
welchem fach die ware liegt der kicker
schnappt sich die ware und bringt sie in
einer schwarzen kiste auf dem weg
die schwarze kiste mit meines presse
bohnen fährt direkt zur packstation und
wird für den versand vorbereitet
beim mehrfach zustellungen gehen die
produkte ein umweg sie werden in braune
kisten umgepackt dann kommen sie an
diesem regal an alle von mir bestellten
artikeln landen in einem fach auf der
anderen seite stehen die pak computer
gibt vor welche produkte in einen karton
berühren und schlägt auch die karton
größe vor nun gilt es das paket
effizient zu bestücken
erst jetzt wird das versand etikett
aufgeklebt bis zu dieser station lagen
die bestellungen für die mitarbeiter
anonym
aniston hat 13 eigene verteilzentren
eines davon befindet sich hier in
raunheim in der nähe des frankfurter
flughafens von hier aus werden kunden im
rhein-main-gebiet beliefert wir sind
hier in raunheim in einem verteilzentrum
in der letzten meile von amazon logistik
und wir bereiten das paket vor das es
zum endkunden geliefert werden kann
meine kaffeebohnen sind jetzt hier
gelandet
mitarbeiter sollten die pakete nach
address gebieten und samen sie in
taschen die gitter rollwagen werden den
fahrern zugewiesen und auf vorgegebene
position geschoben
der fahrer holt sich sein kutter
rollwagen und belegt sein auto für die
tour der computer berechnet in welcher
reihenfolge die kunden anzufragen sind
irgendwo im wagen liegen meiner
espressobohnen es kann losgehen
11 partnerunternehmen fahren von montag
bis samstag die halle an das alles zu
organisieren ist ein wahrer kraftakt ja
wir mehr als 400 fahrzeuge pro tag
abfertigen können wir das ist
gleichzeitig machen
wir haben ein sogenanntes zeitfenster wo
die verschiedenen service partner
ankommen dann als gruppe in die belange
aller einfahren beladen und dann wieder
ausfahren über die amazon app lassen
sich die letzten zehn stationen des
vaters nach
das funktioniert momentan nur mit
auslieferung von amazon logistics dem
fahrrad bleiben pro kunde nur wenige
minuten
gestern bestellt heute da ungeduldige
können bei vielen produkten auch die
drohung am selben tag auswählen auch
meine bohnen haben die reise geschafft
jetzt fehlt nur noch die kaffeemühle